people have stopped buying Macs so much
so that Apple stopped producing their
new M2 Chip now I'll explain why and why
this is actually good news for all of
you and why you guys should wait and not
buy a Mac either and for those that
really need to get one right now how you
can get the best deal possible Apple
just gave us the report that their Max
sales fell a whopping
28.7 compared to their last quarter and
Macs are actually selling worse than
every single other category including
the iPad wearables of course services
and the iPhone and the crazy thing is
the previous quarter was bad as well
falling 22 in quarter four so why are
people all of a sudden not buying any
Macs well there are four reasons the
first one is the fact that the Apple
silicon Max that came out in 2020 are
still excellent they could do everything
from basic web tasks all the way up to
4K video editing even playing with high
bit rate footage that my Mac Pro would
stutter through and they would have no
issues at all now because these Macs are
so good people don't feel like they need
to upgrade three years later to buy
another one they work excellent now with
that when everybody was staying at home
a lot of people are watching YouTube
videos they were working from home they
needed to buy a good machine and Max
sales went through the roof even just a
year ago Mac sales were growing at
Double the rate of PCS when people
needed to buy computers and windows fans
were switching over to these Apple
silicon machines and half a year ago
when the PC market was in Decline
already Max a feels we're still growing
at 9.3 percent which was great for Apple
but this can only go along for so long
because when enough people get their
hands on these great machines and
they're not working from home as much as
they used to they're going back to the
office and the machines are so good you
don't need to buy another one now with
that these M2 powered machines are not
really that great now they do have some
improvements I've talked about battery
life low power mode we have a new design
for the M2 MacBook Air but Apple raised
prices they made their ssds worse even
if you spend 2 500 on a 16 inch M2 Pro
machine the base model is half the speed
as before and there's just not enough
reasons to want to get a new machine so
people are just not buying them and we
also have new Macs that people are
waiting for which I'll talk about in
just a bit now with these Max sales
dropping the crazy thing even at 22
percent for quarter four if we look at
the PC Brands they are getting destroyed
Lenovo has a negative 35 percent uh
growth HP negative 42.8 negative 42 Aces
negative 25 the whole Market is tanking
like crazy while apple is doing quite a
bit better now along with that Apple
knew that Mac sales are going to decline
and they spoke about this there's only
so many people that want to buy a new
machine and because of that Apple
completely halted M2 Chip production in
January going into February because the
sales are really slowing down so with
the whole PC market being in a downturn
they stop making those chips and that is
actually a first for a current gen chip
it is getting that bad and when they
resume production they're only making
half the chips they used to make now
people are also being a lot more careful
with their money buying less Tech things
everything has gotten more expensive for
your cost of living so even Foxconn
recently said they have a 21 drop in
revenue and it's gonna get worse so we
are in a recession people are being very
careful which is a good thing but a
benefit that Apple has is that Apple
users are very loyal there is recently a
study they came out showing how fast
users would replace a broken Apple
device and looking at this chart here 45
of people would immediately replace
their iPhone with 27 people coming in
for an iPhone and a Mac and a large
majority of it would do it very very
soon so when it comes time to upgrade or
replace people are going to stick with
apple announce the answer with the two
benefits are for you the first one is if
you do need to buy a Mac right now you
can get some absolute blue killer deals
on a brand spanking new Mac you can get
up to 300 bucks off a new 13-inch
machine or a 16 inch machine starting at
eleven hundred dollars now that one is
the M2 MacBook Pro which does have a few
benefits over the air but personally
even cheaper than that for 1049 you can
get the M2 MacBook Air which I greatly
prefer you got the Mac safe you got the
new design it's fanless the performance
is still excellent and that is a killer
price for one of those machines but what
is even better than that is the original
2020 M1 MacBook Air that you can pick up
for 799 dollars which is crazy now we
have all these linked down in the
description below if you guys want to go
pick one up this one has fast SSD
storage it is a killer machine and I
would highly recommend it now if if
you're somebody that doesn't mind buying
a used or refurbished MacBook you can
get one even cheaper than that 715 bucks
or if you look for a used one even about
600 bucks you can pick one up in really
great condition and even for a 14 or 16
inch MacBook Pro look at this
1529 for a Mac that costs 2500 new and
on Amazon you get a 90 day money back
guarantee no matter what so if you don't
like it if you change your mind you can
send it right back no questions asked
which is excellent now for the second
part of this why is it good if you don't
need one right now well we know that
apple is coming out with new Macs part
of the reason why the Slowdown
production could also be because of the
M3 chip now if a Dean did an excellent
video on the performance of that it's
going to be a big upgrade in terms of
performance thermals battery life you
guys could check out the video after
this one but we also have the 15 inch
MacBook Air here which is probably going
to be the best selling product out of
their whole lineup you have a larger
screen but at a lower price something
they have never done before at least
probably about 15-20 years and it's
going to be a great all-around machine I
cannot wait so if you're looking for
something like that that is another
reason why people are waiting to pick up
something that is an excellent Mac now I
think I'll probably do an updated video
on that by itself if you guys want more
info you guys can go ahead and click
that subscribe button above check out
vadim's M3 video right over there let us
know your thoughts on this whole Max
sale slump and I'll see you in the next
one
[Music]
thank you